hey guys it's justine and i'm getting in
the extreme festive holiday spirit by
decorating a christmas tree today and
i'm excited because i'm joined with my
sister here she's hiding behind the
other christmas tree you can see me i
can see you you're standing right next
to me i didn't think they could see me
so i have a christmas tree here in case
this christmas tree doesn't look good
because sometimes when you buy things on
the internet you never know what you're
gonna get so i ordered produce on amazon
and i thought this was the zucchini that
i was getting this is the zucchini that
i actually got huge thank you to
lastpass for sponsoring this video you
guys know i've worked with them in the
past and i'm such a huge fan because i
use so many different devices and what
lastpass is is basically alleviates the
trouble of having to re-enter your
passwords but the best part about it is
they can auto-generate passwords so that
they can be super secure secrets super
secrets can't hack this lastpass will
autofill your credentials your usernames
your password so it makes it super
simple anytime you have to log in that's
nice i can never remember anything so
that's great i know it's great it'll
also autofill on your computer on ios on
android so if you guys want to check it
out i'll put a link in the description
to get more information with that being
said
now's the time to start decorating oh
boy
what have you got a knife for me
why don't you have a holiday splatter on
it's red
whoa good thing you were not right here
believe me i've learned my lesson i
think i would have cut you
i know
i know oh i got the box
i'm loving this christmas royalty-free
music that i have chosen for this video
are you enjoying it well you can't hear
it yet because i have to add it in later
but the joke is it's a joke it's funny
it's not even
give me that
why look at our little tree
split christmas music oh i hope i can
find an edm remix
[Music]
what are these moves we don't go to the
club
the last time i went to the club i can't
i couldn't even handle me right now i
was like exactly
oh it's not a stumble
what is this how many feet is it
actually don't know
i started four and a half feet what does
that mean i'm five
three means we're going to need more
height we can use half of it
look at which side what i don't have to
use the hole
i'll just hold it i feel like a statue
of liberty
which side do we jam in first
that's
not what don't even she said that
doesn't seem correct
i'm helping
yeah i just think you jam it in because
there's actually no other way i'm unsure
four feet i mean that's pretty that's
like that's like if you cut my head off
oh it goes in
so picture me without a head i wonder
whatever happened to that tree is that i
decorated with ro last year
put this around the tree okay
just see how you got me in there
the most important thing before you
decorate a tree is make sure the lights
work so you did it wrong
wow
can i get rid of a small tree how about
i put it back here for decoration get
rid of that well the box was small what
are we doing
we're decorating the christmas tree in a
very festive text spirit oh cut my head
off and see for the same size no you're
not close let me see what i have in here
oh my stockings look they're gonna be
hung with care
oh my gosh remember these from last year
i was like do i get rid of them no
because we're gonna need them this year
get freaking festive put that on your
head these i got last year and since i
didn't get a christmas tree last year i
didn't take them out of the box but
these are incredible they are star wars
ornaments i remember these were from my
video
i have no idea what i made though oh all
right stacked get stacked she says so
sometimes like when i think about like
how did i get to this point in my life
that this is something that i'm doing
well i have three things
what's this
stop putting things on me
come on we gotta celebrate yeah but look
how cool this is gonna be i want to show
you this
what is happening to me right now
[Music]
no stop i can't see here's the problem
i don't have anything to hang them i
just want to look here
i don't have any
i do i do are you serious oh i've got a
high you are a freaking
genius we've got a tie fighter where do
you guys see these they're gonna freak
out i wonder if they have them for 2018.
these are the 2017 ones this is so cool
okay we don't need to raise your voice
we're gonna put
it up front and center but wait i have
to plug it in it has to be plugged in
with this if you plug it in but yes it
makes noise duh
[Music]
i dropped him be very careful it's the
only thing that i care about i dropped
it you didn't care enough to get
ornament hooks well i thought that they
were included i thought so too i
actually almost made the same mistake
what a racket what's a racket no
ornament hooks
do you plug them all in
yes and then they they interact with
each other
star wars is incredible i i sometimes
wish that i would have seen it as a
child like i didn't see star wars until
i was an adult so i definitely had a
different experience so i thought that
because i have a lot of like tech stuff
around the house you know i get a lot of
gadgets throughout the year that i
thought it'd be really fun to take some
of those gadgets and make it into a
tech christmas tree okay what else do we
have
that looks good gosh i'm loving came
with ornament hooks yes
this is my garmin it's my satellite
phone because jen and i once got lost
from the forest
that may have been a search and rescue
there may have been a search and rescue
called and i decided that
this is probably
we haven't used it yet that could save
our life oh it's beautiful
i mean i might as well just put this
over here too like
why not i don't think that's where it
goes i can do whatever i want because
it's my tree in my video so if you brag
me
i will sass you back
oh yes
the lenovo you're still on the rock you
gotta get up here standalone headset
have you seen the treetopper 2018 baby
everything this is everything period
like the kids say
that's good i'm gonna get us some cables
this will be
that'll be like the um you stay down
there you're an ornament but you're like
no it's like the train that you put
around the tree this is a very
expensively decorated christmas tree
the one plus usbc cables are making a
beautiful little ornament here these
ones haven't even been unwrapped
it looks good with some oh akg
headphones gotta have them on your 2018
christmas tree
art's here
oh that looks so good
i've got some things
i've got the insta360 one x camera like
we need to leave this hanging up for
forever yeah i can't ever remove it this
nintendo switch controller is actually a
perfect ornament so i've got this
oneplus phone here um i feel like oh
geez i feel pretty good about it i feel
good about what we know it's missing
something are you gonna put the dyson
vacuum on it
i was
but
i don't know why
no
what have you done well i think the
dyson is my favorite part
it's so good was that fishy it wasn't
that was this year yeah so most of this
is 2018 tech other than the spark that
was like last year one of these
christmas ornaments for 2017. but i am
very happy with how this looks so we're
going to somehow move this into the
living room without disturbing the piece
i just saw this phone up there
we've got the oneplus 6t
i mean this is really a work of art and
i'm super proud of it so jenna thank you
for participating in the first annual
tech christmas tree i had a good time
next year it's gonna look like i don't
know depends on what tech is out uh well
thank you guys so much for watching a
huge thank you to jenna for being in
this video and participating go check
out her channel i'll put a link in the
description and
that's it happy holidays merry christmas
if you celebrate
happy new year i don't know when i'm
posting this video i'm pretty sure it's
still 2017. it's 2018 17. oh my god that
future
a redo a do-over oh
i don't ever want 2018
to happen again but look at the great
tech that came out of it this is a
redeeming factor
all right i'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you